welcome to Startalk here at BAM yes it
is now my incredibly great pleasure to
bring on your host a wonderful man a
hero to science ladies and gentlemen
Neil deGrasse Tyson
[Applause]
as promised there's Neil I will now
bring on our two comedic guests tonight
ladies and gentlemen Michael Ian Black
thank you hello Michael and the always
delightful Paul Rudd welcome Paul
[Applause]
just-just - ramat to remind you so
handsome remind you of what Startalk is
it is a paul rudd [__] said that
wrong we like to have fun with science
and we always have comedic co-host and
we go live we have more than one and now
for our eyes our sign that this is the
science side of the house right here
[Laughter]
first let me introduce this is her
second time as a guest on Startalk live
she's professor of cognitive
neuroscience at Columbia Presbyterian
have their Berlin come on Heather
[Applause]
I stumbled not because I didn't remember
a name but in fact it's Mount Sinai
Medical Center not Columbia so my
apologies there that's your second time
thank you this was a neuroscience show
we have one more guest and she's I'm a
big fan of hers in many ways you've seen
her on television you know of her
please welcome warm Brooklyn welcome to
mayim bialik from the Big Bang Theory
[Applause]
this is a hell of a lineup I'm just
saying what they're thinking yeah yeah
yeah so we're gonna talk about the brain
the whole next 90 minutes three segments
we're gonna talk about the brain and
you're here because I am you have a PhD
in neuroscience you don't only portray
one who does on TV you actually have one
right yes I'm a doctor and I play one on
TV
you do both and so you also have a new
book that just came out on being a vegan
correct okay we have 12 vegans and I try
to see how do I have we veganism into
Startalk
and by just discussing it so and I
noticed that the United States actually
has plans unfunded though they are plans
to go to Mars by 2030 and if you're on
Mars they're not gonna be bringing cows
with them you just found the perfect way
to incorporate it into the season and so
in fact they're developing recipe vegan
recipes to go to Mars because the first
colonists they're you they want to be
able to eat sort of efficiently as it
were not damage the environment of Mars
but don't we need to damage the
environment of Mars to make Mars
habitable Mars is just one cow away from
being a place people could live it's an
interesting what does damage mean if you
change what it is that's damaging it
technically if you turn Mars into Earth
you totally messed with it
right so I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing what was Mars
actually like we don't know but we have
evidence that had running water running
so something bad happen on Mars long ago
and so George Bush just a theory so are
you a candidate for NASA to retain as an
adviser in this capacity no I wrote a
book on the vegan things that I feed non
vegans that they enjoy it has nothing to
do with Mars okay so if it's tasty vegan
food for the skeptic I guess sure I mean
you know I I write for a website called
Keller and I would often write about
recipes that I had made vegan just kind
of in passing and people wanted me to
publish them I'm not like a fancy
celebrity chef like I never look like
this I usually am in sweats and an apron
in my kitchen uh-huh so I wasn't looking
to be a celebrity chef and say like this
is how you should eat it it will make
your family perfect but what I know is
what I've sort of cooked my whole life
and things that I've made vegan that
tastes good this still has nothing to do
with science but it does have to do with
because being a vegan means you're
eating efficiency efficiently given the
ecosystem that matters right so one one
of the reasons that some people do
choose to eat vegan is out of sort of
deference to the planet and
environmental concerns you know it
shouldn't cost more to store to food to
store food than it does to actually give
it to people and sometimes that happens
yeah and so I'm just saying if you if
you make food that non vegan people are
happy with that makes you a really
valuable person why thank you
am I the most person I know I just
wanted to call that to your attention
because NASA has an advanced technology
advanced food technology holding this
like you I know you don't have to know
everyone speaking of someone with a
perfect family I the question is
Applewood bacon is that it's got the
word Apple in it it must be healthy okay
good I was just thinking of your book
pesto pasta for Martians you should jump
in on this conversation so if you go to
Mars it takes six to nine months to get
there and then you have to wait for the
planets to realign by then you can
digest the meat you ate I just want to
point out that most people are are more
omnivores and don't just like I had
nobody just anyway you go on so know
you're there it takes that long to get
there and then you're there for the
planets to a line again it's another
year and a half two years or so so it's
a three four year round trip to do this
so I mean people are thinking serious
and hard about this and until Mars
becomes terraformed you're gonna have to
sort of make do with plants and then
what Paul I okay I read this article and
nothing good ever begins that way except
I read this magazine which magazine we
owe a we we which is French for life and
it was all about and this was I god I
want to say it was about 20 years ago
about the Terra formation of Mars and
they talked about churning oxygen out of
the rocks creating some kind of
let's call it an air shield like an
ozone yeah yeah they would descend above
the planet would trap in the air and in
and we would have these kind of habit
rails greenhouse where we would grow
food we would they would populate the
Mars with about 50 or so people and over
over time it would turn into like
judgement city where it's 73 degrees and
sunny all the time and then you could
have your cows that you were missing yes
well you would eventually you would have
cows because account is a machine to
come you have like 10 for every person
though cuz that makes it count was a
machine to turn leaves into steak what
that is what else is a cow what it was
made for because you certainly didn't
have a question in fact I was kind of I
was talking about it not really knowing
where I was gonna go a lot of big so
good luck with the book and tour now and
we're grateful to the book tour that you
even available to us here no it's true I
I'm actually I'm going on Howard Stern
tomorrow but I did the Today Show and
Rachael Ray and all sorts of places that
people talk about cooking and excellent
yep so good so now another thing we may
know you for is as Amy Farrah Fowler on
the Big Bang Theory
now I actually had a cameo on Big Bang
Theory but I think was before you man
before you became a regular Karen yeah I
was brought on the season finale of
season 3 and then I was made a regular
along with melissa rauch who plays
bernadette about midway through season 4
okay great to have you as a regular
there thank you thank you I'm a fan of
the show and and it's a show if you're
not familiar with the Big Bang Theory
it's the number-one sitcom on
televisions but
otherwise if you're not a TV watching
community it's a caricature of sort of
geeks in their lives and their
professors and I guess that's Caltech oh
it's a group of physicists and one
engineer with only a master's and she's
always teased about yes yeah and so it's
a lot of caricature going on there and
it's been criticized for being for its
stereotypes and I'm thinking it's a TV
show you know let me just let it do what
it has to do you play a I don't know
sexually frustrated like every woman
inside you preach sister so it's just
what's interesting to me is they each
have some kind of psychological issues I
think your your love interest who is
Sheldon I think he comes closest to what
anyone might describe as having
Asperger's there's some other kind of
non social behavior right so he so all
of our characters are you know in in
theory on the neuropsychiatric spectrum
I would say Sheldon often gets talked
about in terms of Asperger's or OCD he
has a he has a thing with germs he has a
thing with numbers you know he's got a
lot of sort of that precision that we
see in OCD and there's a lot of
interesting features to all of our
characters that that make them
technically unconventional socially and
I think what's interesting and kind of
sweet and I think should not be lost on
people is that we don't pathologize our
characters we don't talk about
medicating them or even really changing
them and I think that's what's
interesting for for those of us who are
unconventional people or who know and
love people who are on any sort of
spectrum we often find ways to work
around that it doesn't always need to be
solved and medicated and labeled and
what we're trying to show with our show
is that this is a group of people who
likely were teased mock told that they
will never be appreciated or low
and we have a group of people who have
careers successful careers active social
lives that involve things like Dungeons
& Dragons and video games but they also
have relationships and that's that's a
fulfilling and satisfying life and I
think that's what we really try and show
on our show I never thought to death
that's Heather there since there does
seem to be this trend in society that if
someone is some who finds themself on
some extreme of some behavior spectrum
that you have to put them back in the
middle like everybody else and is that
that a good that can't be a good thing
right
can I tell you what we in the Church of
Scientology I think there's a movement
in psychiatry now so well I think
labeling is important in certain
respects because it can help clinicians
talk about people in a certain way it
can help with treatment but there are
other there other you know negative
aspects to it people can get you know
labeled with something that's sticks
with them for life and difficult to
treat Psychopaths because they don't
present I mean the Pope the whole they
don't go like Psychopaths no so people
normally come for treatment when they're
feeling distressed and there are a lot
of people who are labeled with a
disorder who can get on perfectly fine
who don't necessarily need treatment and
even then it's not a disorder it's just
an order yeah it just has to do with the
amount of distress it's causing to the
person and now I think like the new DSM
which is the diagnostic Statistical
Manual that we use to diagnose different
psychiatric disorders has now actually
taken away the label of Asperger's and
now things like autism or pervasive
developmental disorder or Asperger's all
put under this name of autism spectrum
disorders well and also Thomas insula is
trying to sort of do away with the
structure of the DSM four or five as we
know it to say to say more that
are all along along the lines of many
spectrums right so yeah so the way that
that so Tom Insel is the head of the NIH
the National Institute of Health and the
way psychiatric diagnosis is going and
the way that I apply for grants let's
say to do research is that instead of
saying I want to study a disorder
because a lot of people with different
psychiatric problems can be labeled as
one disorder we're now gonna look at
these different dimensions and say okay
is this person having problems like
emotional instability or impulsivity and
try to find a neural basis of those
particular traits and treat that rather
than the disorder I'd never think of it
as a disorder this is good so the Big
Bang Theory is leading the way in this
we are at the for discussion I know like
I sometimes suffer from depression and
when I get stressed out I just burned
down a building now instead of taking my
pills that works great for me did you
learn that from burning down wait wait
so so do they have a neuroscience
advisors on the show I met the physics
advisor there dr. Salzburg yeah David
Salzburg where do you got your PhD and
my undergrad degree yeah we have a
physics consultant who he also has you
know a vast knowledge of general science
as those of us who are trained in
science tend to we have you know a
smattering of this and then I use him
for even the neuro stuff oh yeah I mean
we have a really exceptionally
intelligent interesting group of writers
many of whom have science backgrounds
but yes sometimes I get strange emails
like what part of the brain needs to be
not working for us to have this happen
or you know what should a me be doing in
her lab or we had a couple scenes in the
episode we just filmed where I needed to
have three different activities that I'm
doing in my lab and you know Amy's lab
is not a perfect neuroscience lab or a
neurobiology lab so I tried to at least
make things look you know authentic for
what we're doing it's not always perfect
get a lot of interesting comments like
why would she be doing research and
social effect in capuchins if she's also
counting spores you know I had that
question
[Laughter]
you don't need me to confer on this but
the the the white boards that had
equations on the episode that I appeared
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so it had equations drawn from my
research right and then the guy asked me
said did you recognize something it
turns out he got equations from another
Tyson doing research and astrophysics
[Laughter]
male model Tyson Gay so is there a in
your own life experience or in the show
tell me about women in science has that
treated and thought about and um gosh I
mean lots of different ways in my
personal brain but in terms of sort of
you know presenting or representing a
female scientist you know there were no
other neuro scientists at my audition
you know when I auditioned to play me
Farrah Fowler it was a group of very
talented actresses but you know as
actors we are we are paid to play
whatever's on the page we don't have to
really be that in real life like so that
that was really just sort of an accident
I feel very lucky I was so disappointing
I learned Raj was not an actual yeah
yeah we're all actors no but you know I
think when people especially criticize
or say it's such a stereotype you know I
know people like all those characters I
promise I hang out with them sometimes
no I I know
I know women like Amy Farrah Fowler I I
was asked to do an you know a female Jim
Parsons impression was literally the
audition I had never seen Big Bang
Theory and I was told they are looking
for a female Jim Parsons I said that's
great it was Jim Parsons and I I googled
Jim the night before and I saw about 10
seconds of him doing his Sheldon bit and
I thought I can do
you know I know people I know tons of
people like that so yeah so I I didn't
have to present as a scientist per se
that way but a me is based on a few
female professors in particular and a
few male professors as well yeah yeah I
mean I I spent 12 years in academia I've
met a lot of interesting people in in
neuroscience so yeah she's based on a
lot of real qualities and and real
things that exist and there's all sorts
of men and women in in science and you
know there were professors in my
department who looked like models both
male and female and there were those
that looked like the characters on Big
Bang and you know the fact that we
present Amy as sort of a you know frumpy
like they dressed me a couple sizes too
big and very kind of low on the
aesthetic level that's not a statement
that women scientists can't be
attractive that's a very specific thing
that our writers wanted to craft for
this Sheldon Amy relationship but the
Bernadette character is a microbiologist
and she gets to wear false lashes and
she wears you know fancier clothes than
I do but I love that I get to you know
go to work and put on slouchy clothes I
have to wear Spanx I don't have makeup
like it's very comfortable to be that
kind of person and scientist I wonder is
there any correlation between extreme
science talent and absence of social
graces Heather is there any research
reason why I asked it because that's the
stereotype it's been with us forever and
it's exploited on the Big Bang Theory
game one stereotype that's not true my
name too well I mean so people in
academia there is a stereotype and the
reason for that sir type is there there
are a lot of people in particularly the
sciences and engineering that that think
very you know you have to think very
methodically and the types of
personalities the types of dedication it
takes to be an academic is is innocence
you have to be a bit a social so I think
it attracts people who tend to be a bit
a social who think very rigidly you need
to be a bit obsessive compulsive about
whatever it is that you're studying what
is it that it attracts a social social
people or that the field does not reject
a social people the way so many other
fields would yes do
there's one false coral one thing that
people think is that it necessary to
these personality characteristics and
that's not particularly true there's not
a higher high correlation between high
intelligence and say Asperger's so I
think it's more that it attracts people
to that field rather than it's
correlated per se with high intelligence
so ok so and of course in the big banks
there everyone there is like wicked
smaht right that's everybody you've got
I just I just gift over a note here I
want to go back to it after you got your
PhD you were a school teacher I taught I
designed a curriculum for neuroscience I
taught in the home school community in
Los Angeles for junior high in high
school I did basic neuroscience I
designed a course on technological
advances in neuroscience I also taught
high school biology in the home school
community and it's so crazy because our
resumes are almost like well what does
it mean to home-school so often for for
often for higher level classes like
junior high and high school science a
tutor or a teacher is hired and you meet
usually in a home sometimes people meet
in parks or community center pack of
kids there who I mean I taught I taught
10 you know high school students who
were getting ready to start taking
Community College and yeah I was like
the person on the Big Bang Theory was
their biology teacher is kind of freaky
for them ok and you've also involved in
a stem initiative I've been reading yeah
I'm the spokesperson science technology
I'm the spokesperson for Texas
Instruments which is that really yeah
I've been their spokesperson this is my
third year so I've had a I had a TI 81
depends on how old you are what ti
Virginia
people my age Terminator that comes back
to killing calculator so I got mine I
think when I was 14 and that same
graphing calculator took me all the way
through junior high high school into
college and grad school but I there's a
new one called the ti-nspire that now is
in color and you can download images and
you can create parabolas from
basketballs being images of basketballs
being shot it's exciting and so there's
also a bunch of physics book that was
great covered in a bands I love in my
day there was the there was the TI
people and then the HP people who had
reverse polish notation and those are
the cool kids there's still that debate
in my community it's between Twizzlers
and red vines that's what they do with
the calculators we got I know alright so
some I am there's also everyone has odd
relationships with their parents yet
your your I mean in the show alright
your character we had we don't know your
real so there will your family come into
it there was one episode with it was him
laughing it'll be funny in a second uh
there was an episode where Amy wants to
convince her mother that she's dating
someone this is before she and Sheldon
were dating so she asks him to pretend
like he's her boyfriend and they Skype
with her mom so there was a mom scene
and he says derp cuz he's trying to
convince Amy's mom that they're dating I
just made love to your daughter's vagina
and that was the end of the Skype call
[Laughter]
well on the subject of sex in the Big
Bang Theory there's a lot of sexual
tension everywhere you have this sort of
dual attraction to Sheldon and to penny
amy is bicurious
bicurious there's a word for that okay
you're in Brooklyn
it's bicurious in it it's it's it's
charming to watch that yeah there was a
lot in in season four there was a lot of
the the understanding that for for some
people and amy was one of them who
arrived late to kind of social
interactions like that and especially
sort of sexual feelings and and feelings
of intimacy there's an appreciation of
all kinds of beauty and obviously
Sheldon is very attractive to Amy for a
lot of reasons but penny is as well and
and there's also Raj I think there's a
canary he's by interest what was the
word thank you that makes me very happy
somebody doesn't go on Craigslist well
to take us out of this first segment
there's a there's an episode through the
Gotha which deviation I think it was
called where there's a discussion about
modifying people's behavior and Sheldon
modifies Penny's behavior by offering
her chocolate and she changes her
behavior like instantly essentially for
this and that brings up the question do
you modify behavior by training people
to learn how to behave or do you just
reward good behavior and punish bad
behavior
yeah what's weird where are we on that
and like BF Skinner it was famous for
for food
well BF Skinner his idea was he took it
to a very far extreme behaviorist they
all thought that we're but he did this
with his kids he might have made you
have a newborn children who write books
about their but no so so his idea was
that were born sort of tabla rasa blank
slate and you can make anybody into
anything just by training by giving them
rewards and punishes and modifying their
behavior accordingly well we know now is
that we're born with certain genetic
predispositions to behave in certain
ways and then within that sort of within
that range of you can you can modify
behavior within a range that you're
given biologically so for even something
like intelligence for example you can be
born with a genetic predisposition to be
within a certain let's say IQ range then
your environment can push you sort of
towards the top end of that range or may
be you know towards the low end of that
range but you'll never exceed so it's
almost it's stuff that everyone says
it's a combination of both but there's
definitely a lot of learning that occurs
and we're knowing now from mapping out
the brain and and looking at the genome
that
what seems to be most affected by the
environment is the way the brain is gets
wired so you're born with certain
genetic predisposition terms of the
structure we've got that in another
segment but let me just ask is it is can
you teach someone math faster by giving
them candy than just by teaching this I
mean I'm just wondering or holding them
underwater and being like waterboarding
I guess I'm just driving waterboarding a
towel on the face a little bottle of
water well we know that people sort of
discount delays with rewards so if you
give someone like a reward right away
though they'll put more emphasis built
they'll want that rather than waiting
for a wisely issue there is motivation
and not necessarily sort of a skill set
and a cognitive ability or a technical
ability so the fact is candy makes
everything better no matter what you're
trying to learn because it's a very
strong motivator and it's a potent
motivate it might not make you better at
math but it might make you study for
longer for example cocaine do for my
math learn French in a week all right so
okay so a little of both might help I
guess yeah I mean this is this is the
gold star that children get in
elementary school right that's I mean it
does work to a certain extent as I said
it'll help motivate behavior but it
won't sort of give you a skill set that
you know you don't sort of have well and
I think also as parents it's one of the
early things we learn when we're talking
about how we discipline children and
waterboarding joking aside threats and
fear and punishment and pain are very
very strong motivators to change
behavior the the do you want to
condition a child with fear is a much
larger question which is probably not
funny at all and I won't go ahead
reinforcement and negative reinforcement
there's also taking away of a positive
which can be another way to help
somebody learn so there's a whole
variety of ways you can model behavior
I'm taking away of so someone lives with
the positive you threatened to take that
away
tell me it's not a positive I don't have
a child so let's fire up saying all this
I have two children and it's fine that
you're saying one last bit before we
take our break sir short the just
regroup here so unless it's crazy and
about on the shows you have like live
rhesus monkeys or something
are they projected in or they really on
the set yeah we have we have real
capuchin monkeys wow I'm a vegan you
shouldn't ask me too much about that
monkey on edge you had real Reese's
Pieces right now service say whoa
[Laughter]
well week two when we come back on star
talk radio more from the Brooklyn
Academy of Music start talk radio give
it up for our panel
thank you I want to thank you all for
coming we've got two more segments each
is about a half hour and then we're
going to open the floor to questions
we'll have a microphone in the aisle
that's because that's how we roll
and I can I get the house lights up just
briefly there's someone in the audience
I just want to introduce to you all
there's there's a
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
why not yeah comedy right here there you
go Beantown thanks for showing I'm sorry
let me up he's following me I'm great
there you go
Bill Nye the Science Guy now bill you're
not actually the person I was first
gonna introduce you bring the lights
back up again please the house lights so
we have we have in the audience he
doesn't always being introduced he
didn't know this but I it's I will fill
Larson please stand up well where are
you look there he goes so Larson
everyone is you don't know who he is yet
hold your pause until you find out who
he is he's the first person to ever eat
a baby
Marcin comes to us from the President's
Office of Science and Technology Policy
so he's representing the White House
here at this Startalk
thanks y'all for coming all right okay
how's the lights can come down and we
will begin the second segment are you
ready okay we are back start talk radio
love it band and Bill thanks for joining
us
oh no it is I who must thank you no no
so we want to take this deeper into the
brain we are all neuroscience today I
what is Heather what is consciousness I
mean that's a great question and
self-awareness yeah don't pull any
punches just let us have it and might
you know my biggest question is yeah how
come
identical twins don't think they are
each other that's your biggest question
I think why am i me and not you and we
can take those were different people but
if you have an identical twin you're the
same person but you know just by that
much
so what's up with that well first of all
what is consciousness we can define
consciousness very simply as
first-person subjective experience so
you only are aware that you have it I
don't know what your consciousness is
like I only know what it is from from
internally so what is consciousness
first person supposed to experience how
is it tied to the brain we're still
trying to figure that out now that's
different than self-awareness so you can
be conscious without being self-aware
like in a coma or sleep like my old boss
[Laughter]
bill I don't think you ever had a boss I
know I used to have a job well so for
example babies they can be conscious
meaning you can have some raw sensations
like seeing the color red or feeling
something soft or smelling a rose
without being aware of oneself or having
sort of metacognition like thoughts
about other thoughts I'm the one having
these thoughts so if we're gonna say
another animal is not conscious but has
is not self-aware but has consciousness
that bill the bee finds the flower and
and nature goes there are syndromes also
where we see that people have an
experience of being conscious of
experiencing things in the environment
correct without a notion of concrete
self-awareness
yeah there's certain dissociative
disorders where people lose their sense
of self but they're still conscious
so if consciousness is very unique you
don't need to have necessarily memory
for it you don't need to upset seems to
be displaying this I read articles check
out this magazine years ago formation of
Mars I talk to you about saying a baby
could hear Bruce Springsteen but like
not know why it's having so much fun
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what about lucid dreaming yeah so I mean
it's just another it's another form of
awareness your brain is in a different
state it's conscious but it's just in a
different state of awareness what is
lucid dreaming as opposed to dreaming
and you think so lucid dreaming is sort
of when some people are able to be in a
dream and know that they're their selves
dreaming and they can sort of control
their dreams can I say been there done
that okay well right so a lucid dream is
a dream that you're self-aware you're in
yeah you have these all the time where I
will
I often well I mean I speak other
languages I speak Spanish and I speak
Hebrew and I will often have a dream
where the night
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my PhD wasn't enough anyway sometimes I
will be trying to consciously figure out
how to communicate something in my
non-native tongue I know that I'm having
a dream where I'm trying to communicate
and I'm literally computing what to say
and how to say it and in which tense but
I'm very I'm very aware that this is
going on yes so normally in a dream
state that part of the brain is called
the prefrontal cortex is sort of down
regulated it's sort of decreased in
activations so that you're normally not
so aware of what's going on and these
subcortical sort of processes are
allowed to sort of come through without
being monitored subcortical profit
subcritical processes that are across
the limbic system the emotional part the
amygdala normally so it's pretty active
in a dream state this reptile brain this
limbic emotional brain and the
prefrontal cortex is I have erectile
brain in lucid dreaming you can be in a
state where you can actually engage the
prefrontal cortex a bit more and have
some self-awareness infuse this dream
state so you see that on an MRI while
somebody's asleep are we able to do that
or can you light it up while someone's
unconscious so there's a lot of study
sleep studies which usually don't use
MRI because you have to put them in a
exactly it makes a lot of noise so
they're eg studies which look at
different sleep states and dreams yeah
and so so so with this I so you tell me
a sleep you are conscious in a coma are
you conscious so that's a really
interesting question so there's new
studies now that are showing there
certain people who are in a coma you can
actually put them in a scanner the one
that makes all the loud noise fMRI and
you can say to them okay we want you to
imagine either say walking through your
house or imagine playing a game of
tennis now they can't respond at all and
we know what a healthy person's brain
would look like if they're imagining
walking through the house or imagining
playing tennis and there's been some
cases of people who we think they're in
a coma and nothing's getting through but
if you just simply
tell them imagine this their brain
lights up in the right corresponding so
hence this this story I thought maybe
was just fiction where you can read
books to a person in a coma and they
might still be yeah and it's not every
person in a coma so they think they did
this we'll whole group of people you
want to hedge your bets read the ball
case but it was maybe like one out of
fifty they found this person really was
having awareness okay it would do those
people are those people more likely to
emerge from the coma yeah so exactly so
they they're now have something called
the PCI which I think it's called the
perturbation complexity index but
basically yeah that's it yeah so what
you do is you actually sort of zap the
part of the cortex with a magnet
transcranial a TMS transcranial magnetic
stimulation exactly and then you look at
if there's a cacophony of activation in
response to that almost like if you hit
a bell and you hear it ring and it's
really loud you know that there's a lot
of connectivity and those people are
more likely to come out of the coma than
if you just give them the TNS the TMS
and the activation only happens locally
in boat do those people ever have
memories of their time in the coma that
varies that very very small and we're
dealing yeah run the stats on this kind
of thing of you know you'd have to take
so many people who would qualify for
this kind of coma study it's a very
small and I wouldn't be you know sort of
making any oh no obviously but yeah yeah
mine said small n meaning small sample
size let me get back to that we are
geeking so in terms of the brain we tend
to think well there was the table Raza
is it you you draw it up and then is it
ossified by adulthood the people there
were all these ideas hypotheses running
around NASA did a study on
neuroplasticity your brain and space
okay don't get back so they were
checking in space you are in zero-g and
so in zero-g you're
we have interpretive dance built that
did not happen in the movie gravity
people's hair did not stand up to time
so down this is a radio show so I see
hair and pushed it up straight as though
they could have done with a little
hairspray and in the movie so you force
a balance which requires not ease
awareness of gravity a gravity vector
other things your your your vision your
your sense of day and night because in
space if you're orbiting Earth the Sun
rises and sets every 45 minutes so this
could totally mess with your rhythms and
they did they did it study and they
found out that the brain has plasticity
to it where in fact you will completely
adapt to those changes not only that
they're the brain builds new brain cells
and in some cases permanently responds
to this environment and so because of
the permanence of some of these some of
this plasticity they were suggesting
that you should not bring kids into
space because they don't know what a
permanent change in a kid would be like
as an adult what is what is it like in
an adult what happens and I know people
have their eyes change shape right
astronauts have eyes you go into space
with fighter-pilot eyes come back and
they don't have very good close-up or
disco I'd be careful though when you say
permanent changes because if you're
talked about neuroplasticity if it could
change one way it could also change back
another way but I think the reason why
not to bring sort of developing brains
into space or children is because
they're critical periods of development
and if they miss certain kind of stimuli
during that critical period then there
could be one you're talking about
circadian rhythm
it's correct among other things yeah
okay got it yeah so talking about the
are I don't want to say awareness I mean
it was a lowercase a our awareness of
day and night you're saying those things
can reset so that you have a normal body
period that is shorter than what it is
if you are on earth not quite a 45 well
it really disrupts your sleep cycle and
so and you don't get it's deeper REM
sleep and that developmentally would be
really really about but here there's not
to mention like my kids pain in the ass
I'm just like an hour-and-a-half flight
[Laughter]
I think if you sort of if there's this
neuroplasticity where your body can
adapt to stress in the ways that were
measured in space why don't we adapt
more on earth why do people stress out
and end up in mental hospitals if you if
your brain can adapt with all this
plasticity that the neuroscientist are
boasting of then why do we have people
just freaking out here on earth well
okay they're two separate things tell me
why so so you can people that well this
is one thing I went around actually met
people at extraordinary abilities way
outside the norm of what we think is
possible extraordinary memory and you
know it's hollering to the pain all
these things so you hosted a TV show
there was a TV on Discovery Channel show
called superhuman showdown and there
were people who actually went around the
world to find people with these
extraordinary abilities one person could
hold his breath underwater for 22
minutes and amazing and you know I saw
it there and not be dead and not be dead
and he could actually could he could he
talked to fish even just a little
but it's it's amazing how far we can
actually push ourselves our physiology
and our brain so I think a lot of what
people stress about is they think they
can't adapt but really we can adapt well
beyond what we think we're capable of
doing why people are in mental
institutions another question I think
they're different you know there's a lot
of the reasons why people are go insane
so to speak but I don't think it's
because of lack of neural plasticity
heavy-metal music beat as I was saying
you can you can you can modify the brain
within certain biological constraints so
if you're born with a certain
predisposition or any interest
structural differences in the brain you
can only push it so far but we can
definitely go far beyond what we think
we can where we can go so do you think
what if we see someone else who has
ability and they're human then can we
all so try to have that ability again
it's within a certain so these sort of
these superhuman people who I met they
all practice very a lot a lot of hours
dedicate you but they also had certain
sort of like the guy who could hold his
breath underwater had a greater lung
capacity in general he started out with
that and then he pushed it further and
further so I think we can all go further
within our particular is this book the
sports gene that talks about sort of the
exceptional athletic ability that we
don't really think about when we see
Olympic athletes they're at a whole
different physiological level than we
even would think about we would think oh
you know Michael Phelps is a great
swimmer no like his arms are really
really long his feet are practically
webbed like his body is
it is weird when you watch some swimmers
at that high level they go about twice
as fast as their bodies are you can swim
I could swim all day I'll never look
like that because I was not born with
the genetic breeding long arms at a web
[Laughter]
pedestrian level talking about sports
you see certain populations like people
from the Dominican Republic which is
such a small country but have a large
proportion of people entering the major
leagues of baseball easy because they
have this is such a dangerous question
we know you're about to have going into
racism although something somebody else
has about sort of observing other people
in peer groups ascending to higher
levels and they're therefore seeing
firsthand what's possible does that make
you more susceptible to those by I think
that's I mean you want it or you want me
think to keep it simple we're gonna just
keep it simple and say there's that's a
huge sociological environmental
behavioral sort of influence but I don't
know I'm writing my dissertation no it's
your well I just think have they found a
gene for baseball that's right i I you
know they're you're born with certain
genetic predispositions towards you know
maybe better athletic prowess but it
gets danger for distribution of
marshaled muscle fibers examined on
earth I think what the recent people are
getting sort of yeah but they were
dancing around it's not can be very
controversial there was a book written
called the bell curve for example about
intelligence and it said okay you know
we did this whole study and look the
populations and X number of people from
a certain type of background have the
highest IQ and others don't
it really can lead to nausea Jews it was
happened to be astronauts
[Laughter]
do what I could to slip in a joke about
synagogues and the major league baseball
because another factor as a baseball fan
another very strong motivator in those
countries is this you can play baseball
all year where you can I was just in
Minneapolis this morning it would be
very challenging that's because the snow
is white the ball is white and then you
also have you also have this
extraordinary motivation of money you
could make it in the big leagues and
have you ever seen that the base of
worldwide baseball the World Baseball
Classic yeah yeah it's mostly like
extraordinary player yeah just
extraordinary players but it's one more
[Laughter]
sweep why the hell do we have to sleep
so what a waste of time that is I think
why the hell do we know we could be
literally learning karate I'm reading
I'm learning I'm having fun I said damn
I gotta go sleep for this to be
semi-comatose for the next eight hours
if an alien came to earth and you're
having a great conversation they say
excuse me I have to lay semi-comatose
for the next eight hours I'll get back
to you don't wonder with that what's
wrong with you maybe they go down 16 why
we sleep latest sort of theory that we
think of that most of the neuro
scientific evidence is pointing towards
this is a way of the brain to sort of
clean itself out so during the day
you're taking in all this stimulation
and and it's almost impossible for your
brains to kind of integrate all of it
every day would be cluttered so at night
what happens is there sort of a pruning
it take it solidifies the information
that it wants to kind of keep and envy
whether or not it's accurate or correct
or anything there's sort of a pruning
that happens and so you know it without
this cleaning out process they looked at
people when you deprive them of sleep
and it causes all sorts of problems
including it can relate to things like
Alzheimer's because of the plaques and
tangles that form actually that sleep is
a kind of a way that helps clear out
those plaques and well things that could
potentially form the proteins you're
saying people who don't get as much
clear she's saying people with
Alzheimer's are simply extremely sleepy
what conclusion are we to draw if you're
sleepy you're gonna get so remember play
baseball it's complicated
well like for memories for example like
if you're studying for an exam actually
you'll do better if you get a good
night's sleep it's not good to just cram
the whole night before because the brain
can then solidify the kind of
associations that were made and get rid
of the nonsense and the noise all right
so so but some people sleep five hours
others nine is it I should the five hour
person be sleeping more than an hour a
person to be sleeping less that it's
hard to say there's no I don't think
there's an exact number on enemy people
there's a lot of things out there that
say you should get X number of hours of
sleep but really everybody's different
some people just don't need that much I
don't get a lot of sleep my feeling is
if I'm if in general we are productive
functional getting the things done that
we want to get done there's gonna be
some variability there for sure okay so
also if you don't get sleep that's like
a form of torture but your brain goes
crazy when happens as people start to to
hallucinate yeah yeah they start to sort
of because again the brain isn't able to
properly prune out and all the
information can get kind of jumbled and
people also if you disrupt REM sleep
exactly but it is sleep is where a lot
of that happen it is an individual thing
because you have people like Edison or
Winston Churchill you know these high
functioning people who slept for four
hours a night or two hours a night
there's actually an extraordinary a
large number of people that Bill Clinton
is another one Margaret Thatcher they
would only sleep very few hours but then
they would take these power naps during
the day and there could be something to
that but they all said they at least
they take those little mini naps and
that maybe the brain can sort of revamp
itself and relaxing so what they found
was that the REM sleep was disrupted by
astronauts who in orbit see sunrise
sunset every 45 minutes they couldn't
get the rhythms going then you just pull
down the shades couldn't get I would
have thought I would have a shuttle
coach class they didn't get the little
i-car studies show that if you deprive
people particularly of REM sleep that
they have to make up for it later on so
that they'll have more hours of REM
sleep when you allow them to sleep later
okay so this is a feature of our human
species not a failure of our design I
mean I mean you know we could design it
better without sleep that'd be great but
so far it's but it's all species right
there's no species that does not need
sleep algae there are low metabolic
periods I would say for all sorts of
vertebrates yes I mean yes yeah period
there's a rest period even if it's not
what we call sleep there is a rest but
from an evolutionary standpoint one
could ask if it's a big advantage to
need less sleep would these people be
more successful become captains of
industry and get extraordinarily wealthy
well there must be something well the
answer is there must be something
advantageous ie incorporating a
tremendous amount of input from the day
that can then help you make different
kinds of decisions more complicated
decisions correct yeah next day I see so
the digested information has more value
to you the day after it's for your
survival but we're evolutionarily I
think there's maybe it's stuff it
there's some animals that sleep with
only half their brain and the other half
is alert it's dolphins where it's so
they're it's part of them is aware for
any sort of let's say predators coming
right sleeping guns and swords yeah
samurai bears all right and is it true
like lions sleep 20 hours a day
something like that yeah is that true
Heather
[Laughter]
talkative neuroscientist alliances 20
hours a day they they do they sleep for
20 hours a day no I want you to do with
your kids no I I went on safari one said
no and I remember learning that the
females do all of the hunting and then
the male lions just go in and then eat
first lot away the kids then then they
go back to sleep yeah they're called the
Predators a bunch of them they're called
a pride Wow a murder of crows a boring
of panelists so I entered our earpieces
moments ago all right so I mine how much
sleep do you get at night I actually I'm
like a five or six hour person as am i
I'm like five and a half hours exactly
yeah and I'm naps of them on the weekend
but during the week I take I take a
Saturday a shabbat nap for about 20
minutes yeah I I give my kids a cookie
and I say I'll be a much better mother
if I can sleep for 20 minutes on this
couch with earplugs and I promise and I
heard how old your kids five and a half
and eight whoa yeah
so when presumably when they were much
younger you got no sleep so well yeah I
mean honestly it's amazing to see what
it's like with a newborn I was a
breastfeeding mom and I was up literally
every two hours for about four or five
years literally every two hours
did you study yourself at that point I
wrote my thesis while breastfeeding my
over I literally laying down nursing and
typing I was doing data analysis and
writing and editing my thesis with my
first son and yeah but it's amazing to
sleep again
and she knows three languages
I just get so five how many hours of
sleep oh now I have a three month okay
and I'm breastfeeding so this is I need
seven and a half your septum or I claim
I'm skilled at the power nap I put in
the hours
okay I put in 2/3 of an hour's power nap
all it really varies I I guess probably
about six or seven although it seems now
I am falling asleep for that 20 minute
power how do me right now speak but uh
at about like kind of 5:30 6 o'clock at
night
generally if I'm flipping around I'm
watching pardon the interruption I
noticed that I fall asleep alright show
on ESPN
yeah about 14 yeah like six day okay so
they know nothing I always sleep five
and a half hours six point four hours
I'd say five to eight with a lot of
afternoon naps after I type out my weird
things
while breastfeeding a dragon okay oh by
the way when all this is over the bar is
open and there's a special drink that we
invented just for this program it's
called the brain freeze so you just go
up there ask for the brain freeze we
invented it's the drink did not exist
before tonight and it has sort of the
color of your brain a brain matter but
it's really tasty
so check it out after the Q&A so you
ready to go back in sure okay yeah we're
back
we are talking about the science of the
brain and I want to know what the future
holds for us I've got it written here
that we have 100,000 miles of nerve
fibers in each brain that's
extraordinary
that's a hell of a computer and but it
still has issues like you know I mean
this brain failure in some people right
I mean so so what is the hope for really
disentangling what all this is and
perhaps being able to fix people have
problems you just go in and snip a
connection or or nip-and-tuck
but what is the future of this well I
mean it's a huge problem actually to
solve to understand how the brain works
and you're talking about a hundred
billion neurons with a trillion
connections possible connections so so
to understand the workings of the human
brain is one of the greatest mysteries
and we're all working on that very very
hard but once we understand how it works
then just like a mechanic I said know
how the car works so that when you bring
it in when it's broken they know how to
go about trying to fix it so knowing the
the underlying structure is the
beginning but is it that reductionist
not to get all philosophical on you
because in physics in physics you can
describe each molecule of air careening
off of another one but that description
doesn't give you the bulk properties of
it you need sort of step back and say
this clot this air has a temperature the
individual particle doesn't have a
temperature we have macroscopic
descriptions of things that enable us to
function because you can't describe
every single little thing do you think
the brain will be intractable in that
way so there's there's what you're
trying to say is that if we understand
if you have the brain well we understand
the mind or is that that's what I think
you're saying yeah yeah yeah so so that
would mean that some people think that
the mind our consciousness is an
emergent property of the brain and
there's it just happens well it emerges
out of the workings of it yeah you
haven't if you have enough circuits
you're gonna get them we're gonna get
this confidence thing called
consciousness they're different there's
something called the the easy problem of
consciousness which isn't that easy
that's to say we can't we can correlate
every single thought with the actual
workings of neurons in the brain and
let's say we can map all that out and we
can do it we saw the easy problem
there's still gonna be a hard problem of
why is it that those neurons firing and
there's no chemical sloshing around
caused us to have these subjective
experiences and we might not be able to
they called the explanatory gap we might
not be able to fully explain that but I
think we have to start somewhere and
just understanding the workings of the
basic system is a good place to begin I
asked a really maybe dumb question maybe
not do we know that consciousness exists
in the brain I would venture to say yes
because I know that when you take out
like half your brain you can still
function right you can take out you know
the left hemisphere and the right
hemisphere will rewire but then if you
were to cut that in half again you only
get a quarter of your brain would you
still have conscious and then what point
does your consciousness disappear how
many objects have you done this
expression but seriously what is the N
on this
[Applause]
yes
when does it move to your feet I mean
it's a philosophical question people say
you know if you take little bits of
parts of the brain away how much you
take away how much with brain do you
actually need for conscious awareness
and some people claim that you only need
the the brain stem well we know that
that's not true because if you take a
full adult you take away their cortex or
they have a damage to the cortex they're
not going to be conscious anymore
however there are children who were born
without a cortex and they just have
their brainstem and they have some
semblance of what we might call
consciousness with these what we call
children of the Damned you can't joke
about it and cephalic but seriously I
love conversations with dogs
I can see dogs are dreaming dogs
experience the joy of discovery mm-hmm
but is a dog paralyzed by self-doubt
actually I think I've even seen that
know a dog with an especially
aggressively disciplining owner seemed
to be paralyzed like I can't cross this
line or the guy's going to hit me and so
do we study how far back do we go from
what is it rhesus what's the guy rhesus
monkey but they have you guys were the K
Farrah Fowler's Kentucky so how far down
do we go then there's a cat then I've
spoken I'll be it briefly with birds and
it's a different deal right so I think
once we do dr. Doolittle
the science guy okay once we have a
measure of consciousness then we will be
able to say does this animal have it
does a baby have it you know when is in
a merchant but until we have an
understanding of what it is so there's
certain theories of consciousness one is
that it's a certain when you have a
system that has a certain amount of
integrated differentiated information
that it will fundamentally have
consciousness that could be a computer
that could be any kind of system a
nervous system so once we have an
understanding of a theory of
consciousness then we can measure it and
see what has it well I think it's
important to think about if you take out
quote half the brain you're essentially
dealing with duplicated structures
existing correct so there's gonna be
some asymmetry between left and right
but you're dealing with half of a brain
that then is pretty much duplicating all
of the structures you've removed once
you start chopping up that half there's
really no more duplicated structures you
can start taking so if there's one
amygdala you can't take away that
amygdala there's nothing to take that
place so if you want to start chopping
up cortex or if you know if there's an
accident that compromises part of cortex
you have other parts of cortex that are
similarly structured that can
theoretically take over some of that
function once you start getting into
those limbic structures in the
supplement all that stuff there's no
more duplications you can't keep like
hacking it in half it's not like a you
know calculus limit like how much can I
leave and still have the person you were
saying chopping up and chopping oh but I
was sitting here just actually thinking
of your vegan roughly robbed with brain
is not bad the really interesting thing
here is that you can actually you can
act you can take away the amygdala which
you haven't you said that way to glibly
okay well I mean if there are certain
people who were born with calcified
amygdalae so they actually they're I
mean they have a disease actually that
calcifies they're made alive so they
become damaged and they no longer work
so you can be let's say you could be you
can not have emotion you can still be
conscious you can not have memory and
you can still be conscious there's a
case in England where
he only remembers things for like 30
seconds so each 30 seconds he writes
down I'm just now conscious for the very
first time and then I'm just now
conscious for the very first time but he
still having awareness so the question
is how much yeah you can take away all
these how much of the brain is necessary
to have so there's something called
procedural memory which is different
than declarative memory persists like
riding their bicycle exactly so when you
learn something like matura clike riding
a bike or tying a shoe so what's
interesting about this case in England
is that he was a pianist and he could if
once he got started playing he could
play the entire an entire piece of music
all the way through as soon as he came
out of it he didn't know where he was
what he was doing whatever but it's a
procedural memories with a different
part of the brain called the basal
ganglia which you can engage in even if
you don't have declarative memories or
like memories semantic memories memories
about things or facts so it looks like
all of your research is happening on
people who have brain disorders but some
of the best ways to learn about the
brain is by seeing what happens in the
natural world when it doesn't work
because of all sorts of legal and
ethical issues we take what nature gives
us but that's you know that that's one
of the things that you know every brain
lesion is different every accident is
different there's a tremendous amount of
unpredictability when you're dealing
with any of these sorts of syndromes ok
so you used brain mapping - will that be
is that the way to go to cure these
horrific brain diseases like Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's just sleep more I had my
brain scan a couple times on camera for
a hilarious science comedy
it seemed to me well you've got your
break because I said bill you need your
brain examined just don't use it that's
all so it looked to me like if you could
get another order of magnitude that is
to say what is the current resolution of
a magnetic resonance image it's looks
like it's half a millimeter yep yeah
yeah it looked to me like if you get
another instead of half a millimeter 50
microns then you'd really be able to
figure out what was going on this is
that too reductionist to your point no I
like reductionism I just was wondering
if if that was the pathway to this is
awareness I converted to reductionism
when I got married the state of affairs
now is that we have this technology to
be able to look at the microstructure of
the brain so we can go in and measure
the activation of one or two individual
neurons in a monkey or even in a human
when they're under during surgery and we
can look at this very microstructure and
then we look at the macro structure or
the activation and things like fMRI
which is like a virtual functional
magnetic resonance imaging which is sort
of looking from very far away but we
need something in between like a meso
level to understand how all these
circuits are wired up because just
looking at where the blood flows in a
certain area that's what fMRI is looking
at is to course exactly and and the
other way is to fine so we need
something in between and there are
certain technologies that are being
developed now things like opto genetics
where you can actually look at the
neural circuitry and control
octogenarian on that and so you've got
photoreceptive organisms you put in the
brain or some proteins yeah and then you
follow the light that they emit is that
sort of like this from Wrath of Khan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that was deep that was these ways to
poke and prod a living person's brain
without doing damage you basically you
can insert you take these photosensitive
from photosensitive allergy you take the
gene that codes for that you insert it
in a virus which then inserts that into
the you just said you just said you get
a photoreceptive virus that you stick in
someone's brain oh I just hear that you
take the gene of the photoreceptive
algae and then you want to transport it
into the brain so you do it via a virus
that's not dangerous you're letting your
virus do your bidding in someone's brain
yeah and so then what happens
virus
it's algae that you attach to a virus
[Laughter]
see if I got this right the algae has
photoreceptor proteins
yes there's no good way to get that
protein into another living body unless
you attach it to a virus with that's
what they do or they're gonna start
replicate they're gonna start
transcribing correct yeah and then what
happens is that now wherever you insert
this gene the now you inserted a
receptor that's gonna be sensitive to
light so now when you shine light on it
the neuron will fire and so what they've
shown let's say in mice for example is
that you can shine a certain like a blue
light and cause a whole circuit because
it's being activated doctor yes
is it that you shine a light and it
causes the neuron to fire or when the
neuron fires it lights up no okay you're
caught I see when you shine the light
the receptors that are sensitive to
light open which then caused the neuron
to fire because then there's a whole
rush of you know
not to me the virus is introducing a
sensitivity which is detectable right
the that's the whole point
this is Schrodinger's the two sides of
this there's you want to repair people
who have real neurological disorders
Parkinson's but maybe you want to make
people smarter or more like you said
superhuman I'd love to throw a car what
do I need to do yeah yeah so so is any
are you or your people are they are they
involved in this work trying to enhance
human intellectual performance so what
there's something called neural
prosthetics and this is where we're
using some of it right now to treat
psychiatric illness where we implant
electrodes it's called deep brain
stimulation to help treat psychiatric
patients but they there's things called
North prosthetics where you can implant
electrodes to help people for example
who are deaf to hear or to help blind
people see and that technology is
already being it's it's it's in pilot
studies now and a field of neuro
engineering exams combining and and
eventually yes we can do things like
enhance memory enhance attention by
using these just like drinking Red Bull
[Laughter]
okay so but you're okay you're you're
stimulating I mean our brain as far as I
can tell is is chemistry and electricity
right I mean is is it something beyond
that it's you're manipulating either the
chemistry of the brain or the electrical
circuitry of the brain with magnetic
fields or whatever else right so all
right so if that's the case I know my
computer uses electrical circuits so is
there a future where we're gonna attach
your brain to a computer yeah I don't
see why not
I mean we already and we already do yeah
we already in a sensor
but there is I have an old question
about magnetism and brains there are
animals apparently that find direction
on their own using some sort of feral
some sort of ferrous iron bearing thing
in their cells in their brains but we
never got that how did that get sorted
out you trying to find true north richer
you want to go more yeah I watch
magnetic cars I'm good with the fact the
fact that MRI machines work indicates
that there are magnetic property I mean
there's all sorts of properties to all
of our bodies so there's there's smaller
lesser magnetic qualities to our body
but no we cannot navigate by them but
maybe you can't ask directions
other animals got all kinds of stuff we
don't have why I have wings
you know newts can regenerate limbs we
can't Meagles can fly we can't I mean
you just go on down the list all right
well I'm a brain well they'd get to that
thing where our our brains really will
be like a computer we can hook it up to
a computer and be able to speak
languages without actually learning them
we will be able to download information
ask my okay I'm ready to bust a gasket
here learning languages are very very
complicated I mean just to use that as
an example
we're not translation machines so in
theory I could picture a world where if
I had a catalogue dictionary I could be
hooked up to something that would allow
me to be a translation machine but the
subtleties of language and interaction
and the way we communicate and answer
questions and have experiences through
language is extremely it's beyond
complicated that you could plug into a
computer but so maybe if not having the
choice
dilemma but you could at least maybe
read a menu in another country sure I
will grant you that yes I know what the
hell I'm getting what I'm in Paris and
champignon so you wouldn't understand
another language but you could
technically translate it hooked up I'm a
travel interesting about the future so
when you when you chew on those pink
pills and it shows you where you haven't
brushed how does that work wait so
Heather do you think I'm gonna actually
rebut I am I am here we who would have
thought who would have thought some
years ago that a computer would ever
beat a human in chess who would have
thought that a computer would ever beat
a human in jeopardy so the computers are
moving pretty fast here so so why
wouldn't the context of language be just
another thing it learns rather than just
a translated dictionary why why what why
should we put limits on the computers
that have transcended limits we've ever
given from them in the past they'll eat
us as babies so intelligence is
different so acknowledge just think
computers if you want to look at that
we're already smarter than us they can
do math quicker than us they can do
calculations they can translate into
languages they're much better in terms
of holding a lot of information and then
why would we even want it and sort of
incorporate that into our brain we can
right now we have our iPhone so we don't
have to remember numbers anymore our
computers do that for us so then one of
the questions is what do you know what
are humans still good yeah in fact the
idea that you'd plug chips in your head
to know things it's this is not a chip
in my head but it's an arm's reach the
same different seconds yeah eventually
that'll get smaller and smaller and
smaller you can implant the iPhone in
your brain and you can talk to it and
it'll give you information so so the
question is where do where does
humans committee people already talked
to their iPhones right I got it I got a
step in as an engineer here I want to
remind you that computers don't just
come out of the sky somebody designs
these things the guys over here I'll
believe it when I see it but then as
forests but then as far as as
communication another language I can
easily envision I guess a pun intended
a computer that can recognize faces and
emotions on faces and then that would
enhance the translation of a language
seriously I don't think that's an
extraordinary step but there's a
communicator there's a famous sort of
impossible sentence for computers where
you say time flies like an arrow
fruit flies like a banana why is that
impossible for a computer because the
two sentences are grammatically
identical they're grammatically
identical yet they have completely
different meanings why couldn't a
computer learn it the way you did many
of the words changed how they were
perceived yeah so what we don't know is
whether the computer then has to have
your life experience a human life
experience is gonna change what the real
thing is will it eventually have
consciousness or experience or
subjective States what is it like to be
never have awareness well now we now we
get to the coring test everybody I said
the Turing test guy just because I know
he's pretty impressive some great
science fiction storytelling involves
power of the mind telekinesis
you know mind control mind reading is is
that is anyone working on this is it in
the future or is it just a pipe dream
yeah so well there's studies let's say
something like mind-reading there
studies now where you you put someone in
a scanner and you show them different
pictures or even movies and you see what
the sort of neural signature
of that and then you again put them in
the scanner the experimenter doesn't
know what they're looking at they're
only reading out their brain activation
and they could very reliably predict
what the person is seeing and then if
you take that a step back and you can
even look at what a person is imagining
so over time the more precise this gets
I can definitely envision someone just
reading someone's neural sort of
activation and and predicting what it is
they're thinking about so you'd have to
walk around some kind of neuro math
riser so that you can detect if someone
is being turned on or turned off or
highly useful social super EXTREME
guestimation like me is not my knitting
you're just talking about a very very
very understand of the brain the closer
you will be to getting right but
successful charlatans or so called
mentalists or magicians they have
disability at some very reasonable rate
probably through facials go ahead oh
yeah there's there's a lot there's a lot
of subtlety that that's not mine reading
right that's a very subtle fine-tuning
into body language gesturing shifting of
basically the air around people but
there's nothing magical mystical about
it your grandmother is here and she
agrees I'm sorry if we take what you're
talking about Heather maybe ten steps
further is it possible in the future it
would be possible to kind of record your
consciousness and then market that as I
would be able to live as you for a day
by by through a sort of kind of VR
virtual reality playback I don't know if
you could ever just say yes
I would buy that URL right now
ground-floor but actually another study
that that I'm involved in we're doing
something called hyper scanning or dual
scanning where we can scan two people at
the same time having an interaction and
kind of seeing what's happening in the
space between two people because as I
said before I can never get into your
brain I really know what you're thinking
and that's what communication is it's
about the space between and now we're
seeing what's happening in your brain
when you're actually really taking in
what I'm saying and vice versa and also
much as you know as scientists I'm sure
we'd all agree yes there are things that
we can't see and that we can't
understand but there are also things
that we know now as scientists things
like pheromones there are things that
occur for example between two people
that are not necessarily detectable in
all the other ways we're looking but
there's something that happens that
again we don't need to write off as
magical and mystical we may not be able
to measure it yet but yes I think we'll
get there in more ways okay so let me
add let's end the show with this this
exploration does if you want Heather
you're on really there I say dangerous
territory because the more you know what
the brain is and what it does as a
scientist what any scientists want to do
it wants to do at the end of the day is
control it yeah
you want it you want that's that's the
evidence that you know what it is you're
doing you want to make predictions make
predictions have those predictions come
true they say I know how this thing
works so if the brain is your laboratory
and you say oh here's this this I've
just discovered what makes two people
fall in love now you make a love potion
number nine and you control people's
behavior in conduct
do you have another team of ethicists
behind you looking over your shoulder at
your conduct
yes it's the CIA I mean there's a whole
field of neuroethics
which are talking about issues but yes I
mean ultimately what we're going is from
correlation to causation when I say
we're going into the brain and
implanting electrodes for a good cause
to treat psychiatric illness we're
controlling emotions and you know if
somebody whose emotions that are
socially regressive yeah so but you can
actually yeah I mean if we know exactly
what the right formula is for sale of I
mean people will you can stimulate an
emotion in someone and they'll label it
as love I mean so so but but no one's
there overlooking my shoulder saying you
know there's an IRB there's a board that
like IRB the institutional review board
that makes sure that you don't make
people fall in love when they're not
supposed okay so so but the day would
surely come where you can make someone
smarter if they can afford to pay you
you could cure them if they can afford
that you have all kinds of neurological
disorders I'm just wondering what is
what is the disc topic future of this
and what is the U topic utopic future of
this well one one issue is that it could
be that only people who can afford let's
say the neural implants get them and
then they have an advantage it's just
like and then everybody will have to so
like performance-enhancing drugs you
know in sports the reason the outlaw
diamonds cuz if one person has if they
have the advantage everyone else has to
do with this name with mental illness
right in terms of access to mental
health care and mental exactly I mean
one person has a mental illness
everybody else no but we're net we're
sort we're I think what you're getting
at we're there there's a dangerous
possibility of sort of narrowing the
field of who is well who is smart who is
desirable who is accessible who gets
access to care that not to bring it down
at the end but that could be dangerous
and so so let me ask each one of you
what's the scariest future of
neuroscience you couldn't think of what
is the you work in this field what is 50
years in the future what is that world
gifted to us by you and your research
colleagues fifty years from now what is
that well what I would hope is that we
can really have a full-scale map of
human brain going all the way from the
genome to function and to minds and
brain and once we have this full map of
the brain and how it works then we can
help prevent things like Alzheimer's so
rather than looking at treatments we're
gonna look at prevention you know if you
can go in and tweak the genome a bit so
that people don't get these kinds of
mental disorders to begin with then we
don't even have to worry so much about
the treatment side of things so that
would be wonderful so you can you treat
the genome in an adult you treat the Jim
in an adult and then that fixes their
brain as an adult that would be great if
we can do that yeah if we can even do it
in the in an adult to change it yeah
gotta ask though from an evolutionary
standpoint why is it that genetic that
mental illness persists if it's really
especially dangerous wouldn't it have
been eliminated from the gene pool so I
suspect it's not in the biggest picture
that deadly to have a mental illness if
it's manageable
that is to say germs and parasites are
much more likely to kill you than being
mentally different and so I just wonder
about this whole thing when you when you
go to predict the future without taking
into account let's say the flu that
killed more people in 1918 than World
War one did and so the other thing is
this is these questions I think are
really only access only useful to a
society that can afford it right the
people that are more successful at
having an overall health in their tribe
or their society might do better than
terms of quality of life there are two
things there one is that certain things
do persist like for example being a
sensation secret being really impulsive
though that's a quality that got people
out there and you know discovered
America right these kinds of traits
which we might call by the way that
probably killed more people than who
actually right yeah I mean there's not
unless they say that everything with
mental illness there are some positive
things about being at the extreme ends
of
of what we consider to be normal there
is no such thing as normal but but what
studies do show is that the most amount
of any disease cancer you know all sorts
of physiologic diseases the thing that
causes people the most poorest lowest
quality of life and distress or mental
illness because they don't die from it
but there you have to suffer their life
and often they have children and pass on
genes that maybe predisposing to to
future mental illnesses it's a really
sad discussion and we gotta wrap this up
so all right what what can what's in
your future personally your personal
future this book it's called my name is
vegan table I work on the Big Bang
Theory and I have two kids and that's my
life let me offer some sort of
concluding remarks here I think we you
know I study the universe and the
interesting thing is that there's this
universe inside our heads that is
perhaps less well known than the
universe that's extends back to the Big
Bang in time and and in space and so I
it's curious maybe the big challenge
here is studying your using your own
brain to study a brain you're not there
you're not some other entity studying
the brain and that prevents some
questions perhaps from even being asked
because you know you don't even know the
right question because the brain is
asking the question about the brain and
Carl Sagan is famous for the saying that
humans conscious humans are a way for
the universe to know itself and no we're
not the universe we're in the universe
and we use our brain power to
decode the universe I'm just I'm
intrigued by the fact that the the real
future here might just be in our minds
and maybe we will learn what questions
we're not asking yet and those are the
questions that keep me going every day
because that's that's the future of
discovery in any field so join me giving
a very warm thank you
[Music]
we its QA time we have some microphones
on the aisles we can bring up the house
lights maybe to half and what we prefer
is just to find one person to direct the
question to because of all 12 of us
answer it takes all night so if you can
be specific about it sir you're up front
hey how are you doing hello um so you
talked a little bit about the idea of
there's these people superhumans right
and so there are people out there who
have what I think is called savant
syndrome who have some kind of amazing
mental abilities they can they can like
learn new languages in a week or do
really rapid calculation so what's
different about these people's brains is
this something we all have inherently
able in our brains and could we hack it
to enable that ability wait wait I
recognize that question you're the guy
who won this contest aren't you yes you
want a cast thank you oh yeah and they
put your first date so how they tell me
the rest are excellent excellent
okay a great question I think you know
we all want some of that ability right
so so what's up with that yeah how can
we think what what savants is what they
seem to be wired slightly differently
and so they seemed up these usually
these isolated areas of specialization
sometimes at the cost of other parts of
the brain development of other parts of
the brain so it's not necessarily great
a good thing to be very very good at
just one thing and at the suck at the
cost of other things and the the only
way I think we can enhance our cognitive
abilities is with working at it it's a
anything like with you know losing
weight you have to work at it so I don't
think there's a sort of magic pill or
but but it has to do it the way that
their brains are wired slightly
differently okay so using the word
wiring so in the future you can adjust
the wiring if you haven't if you have a
if you have a savant is there is there
an ethical question about whether you
would change that about that person yeah
I think there is I think it's it's it
it's what they Kenny thing even with a
psychopath
they don't come in
[Laughter]
you know so if they're not a threat to
other people or if they're not in
distress I don't think that we should go
around just changing people for the sake
of it question here yes since we have
the comedian's here I don't know if you
guys have thought a lot about the
intersection between comedy and
neuroscience I have yes yeah I wrote a
paper on the physiology of laughter in
college right yeah so actually he did it
was all right perfect so um you know
these guys are up here providing great
like comedic interjection and not
everyone can do that like not every
brain works that way so maybe we could
hear from like one comedian and one
neuroscientist like why neuroscientist
who is a comedian go higher why are they
funny why are you I don't know if I can
answer that but I can say that I can I
add that when she wouldn't couldn't say
this about herself on the Big Bang
Theory her timing is impeccable
[Laughter]
Yeah right from 1991 to 1994 she was
blossom on the show and you were the
young Bette Midler in the rose no I mean
I'm happy to let you guys also speak to
it I mean in terms of what's funny or
not you we want you to know but in terms
of what's funny and why are things funny
there is a really interesting field of
sort of understanding the the timing of
how you know complicated it is
it's complicated social interaction but
I think for me as as an actor and as a
scientist what I'm aware of is what we
constantly do is work constantly
scanning and tracking and it's people
can do it better than others
you know stand-ups can do something that
I can't do right I can't do improv
there's there's a different set of
skills that that actors and performers
have but you know the joke that we tend
to be neurotic that we tend to be
constantly looking to make someone feel
something is a very complicated thing
about being an actor and I didn't think
about it as much when I was younger but
but when when you meet other actors and
when you talk about process which a lot
of people laugh they figure like I would
paid to be funny or paid to make people
believe something it's a very
complicated process by which I need to
make you feel something I need to make
you believe something and I need every
single person to feel that so if you're
a stand-up you're working with a room of
people when I work in front of a live
audience I need everyone to feel
something and it's a really complicated
interaction especially if you work with
a live audience it's very different than
then not because it is a constant
tracking of subjects of yours well yeah
actually so this is really exciting
stuff this is a new era of research
we're going to is actually the neural
basis of creativity and improvisation
and so what we find is that whether it's
jazz improv or comedy improv there's a
certain neural signature involved when
people are improvising so you can put
people in a scanner and you can even
freestyle rappers right so you give them
a memorized rap and then they can
freestyle or you give a musician a
memorized piece or improv and when
they're improvising what they find is
that a part of the prefrontal cortex the
medial prefrontal cortex becomes extra
activated and that has to do with
internally generated ideas and the
dorsal lateral part of the prefrontal
cortex becomes deactivated and that has
to do with sort of self-aware and
and monitoring your behavior so you
almost go into this free-flowing state
if you become high too aware you you you
mess up you're not good at improvising
you have to kind of lose yourself so to
speak now at the neural imaging shows I
have a follow-up is there any connection
between improv and optimism I don't know
actually
wait one of the studies showed actually
one of the studies showed that that when
they were improvising they had increased
activation of the amygdala which could
be related to positive feelings that's
interesting to know all right right here
sir yeah hi
every Christian actually had a couple of
questions but then when you guys
mentioned eugenics shades my question
isn't it I was actually all I could
think about was the movie idiocracy now
I don't know if any of you guys have
seen that it's kind of a scary look at
what might happen if if dumb people keep
reading you know okay so my question is
um to the neuro folks over there I don't
know if you've seen anything going in
that direction or not or genetic
predisposition predisposition in society
to become idiots I didn't see the movie
so I can't speak to that well this is
gonna be I'm trying to be like sort of
PC well one of the one thing is that
with with evolution in the past right if
it was survival of the fittest
then those who just couldn't make it
couldn't make it and they would die out
and then there would be certain traits
that would have evolved and survived but
but now we have all sorts of ways to
keep those people exactly
[Laughter]
kind of a in-depth and specific question
gets to the scientists and I guess to
the neuroscientists here based on
quantum theories of the mind what's your
take on the idea that constant
consciousness originates at the quantum
level and if you're familiar with
Schrodinger's equation the very fact
that observing something changes the
outcome so the mind observing
consciousness
what's your guyses take on that yeah I
can offer something on there as well so
a quantitative quantum physics has sort
of mysterious properties that are real
but they defy anything your five senses
or more have ever experienced in your
life so you say well that's weird
but it's real it happens particles pop
in and out of existence you you look at
it and then it changes into something
else this is the this is the behavior of
the universe on the smallest scale
because there has all these mysterious
properties what I have found in my
experience watching people think about
the world is they have this urge to
insert quantum physics where there's
something where they don't otherwise
understand what it is so we don't really
understand consciousness quantum physics
must be at work all right so it's this
yeah and in fact the more they invoke
quantum physics that's the evidence that
they know least about what it is they're
talking about well I admit that I don't
know what I'm talking about I mean I I
do appreciate this notion that any
observation of something alters what it
is how we perceive do we describe it
[Laughter]
when I observe you
you don't pop into a different quantum
state you are macroscopic entity large
things 607 average out the hot these
principles so that we have a macroscopic
world that lends itself to macroscopic
discussions just tell you to sit down
you just want to tell if we were the
size of particles yes me beaming eyes at
you with the light would pop you into
some other part of the universe yes but
you're big so it doesn't happen it would
be cool if you if we were like particle
size and you walked through a doorway
okay you would diffract okay like I mean
it'd be funny if if if Planck's constant
we're much larger than it is weird stuff
would happen all the time okay so yes I
just bring it to the brain for a second
okay so there's a I just want to diffuse
this theory cuz everyone I always get
this question about the quantum theory
and there's this Roger Penrose who's a
mathematician at Oxford and and Stuart
Hameroff who who's the anesthesiologist
they came up with this theory of quantum
the quantum theory of consciousness
basically saying that at some level at
the at the the the structural level of
the neuron is where these quantum
effects can sort of take place and and
that's where consciousness lies and the
rest of it but but there's no evidence
for that and also the temperatures at
which these effects would have to occur
they'd have to be cooler than the
temperature that the brain is currently
at so so there's a lot of things that go
against this idea but again people tend
to want to put together something
mysterious with something else
mysterious but as far as we know from
the field of neuroscience there's no
evidence can I ask a follow-up question
about this okay I think it's quick
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm cutting the line so I cut one yeah
doesn't this imply this idea does that
imply then that consciousness has mass
and do we know that to be true I gotta
say guys as an engineer at some level
you can measure the block with a logic
analyzer or you can measure the voltage
without screwing up the circuit at some
level I don't understand what you're
saying if one day we establish
consciousness as the sum of some
energies within the brain then by equals
mc-squared consciousness has a mass
equivalent that's what I'm saying yes
sir
okay so tonight's discussion was mostly
centered upon human neuroscience for
obvious reasons but there was a few
mentions about neuroscience and
consciousness and whatnot of other
species and we do know that some species
are quite smart and not just like our
close relatives like you know great apes
but also you know toothed whales some
birds like parrots and crows and even I
recently saw the video that looked like
it was unedited of an elephant painting
an elephant
so was it on YouTube no it was not okay
together
was the elephant so P I saw dolphin
playing chess is that real
we're not just like my real question is
what might consciousness be if it has
arisen in different lineages of living
things what might consciousness be for
them and also what might it be for say a
possible alien life here Heather so
conscious big-brained
mammals out there what we learn can we
learn about our consciousness by
studying them you work on lab rats to
learn about work on rats I work on you
but yeah you said I don't work on rats
humans yeah okay yeah we all feel better
about that yeah they're different
different IRB protocol exactly that is
rich to be protocol
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so what's really there two different
things there's intelligence there's
consciousness Abbi can have
consciousness it could feel a sensation
it could it can sense something it can
do something very simplistic so you
don't need to be able to play chess to
be conscious we know that in certain
creatures like in dolphins in whales and
humans there's certain types of cells
called spindle cells especially in
animals that are social and that that
might have some kind of link up to
awareness or at least some kind of a
self-awareness but until we have a
fundamental theory of what consciousness
is we won't be able to know for sure
what that's something guys we only can
look at behavior even with humans in the
lab you have to just ask them did you
see that or not were you aware of that
or not that's the only measure we I saw
a comic of two dolphins
once swimming next to another and
they're referring to the humans up on
the shore and one says one dolphin says
to the other they face each other and
make noises but there's no evidence
they're actually communicating yes right
here yes I have first I have to say what
an awesome panel and Bill you did great
in the debate
[Applause]
I'm really star struck just being here
so but anyways I want to ask two of the
neuro scientists and to Neil because I
think you've been on stage I think a lot
of guys been at stage with them it's a
it's a rather controversial position
held by Sam Harris about one of my
colleagues at UCLA and I by the way let
me preface this by saying I think he's a
he's a brilliant order I think he
communicates very well I just know he's
got some he's a great thinker too but
it's trying to parse out whether it's
whether we agree or not or whether
there's consensus and the question is
about whether or not we have free will
free will
so as far as we know from what if Sam
Harris recently published a tract on the
assertion that we do not have free will
and the evidence cited for it comes from
neuroscience I must answer this I have
no choice free will what's up no it
started with Benjamin Libet studies in
the 1980s and and all the way in some
honest studies now that but the sense of
freewill is kind of an illusion it's
free will is an illusion in the sense
that your brain decides first and you
become aware of it after the fact that
we know this from a whole series of
studies from measuring your observations
even studies now where you can put
somebody in a scanner and you could
predict for example up to ten seconds
now before they're gonna decide whether
to go left or right or press the left
button or right button by just reading
their brain exhibition the brain point
decides
yeah the brains for your readiness
potential so it kind of is gearing up
and you can start to read how the
neurons are firing in that it's gonna go
sort of toward one way or another at a
certain point you can make that
prediction well before the person
becomes consciously aware that they've
decided to go left or right big end -
yeah it's pretty well-established that
yes okay but does that alone negate free
will
well your brain has free will presumably
the brain decides your perception of I
made the decision only comes after the
brain is
so so we are so late I made the decision
is my brain that's I'm making the
decision Frank so let me ask you what is
this phenomenon I sure hope I don't see
my keys in the trunk of my car and close
the lid on it what is that you feel that
you're gonna make a mistake but you go
ahead and make the mistake anyway so
this is this is the thing everybody's
talk about consciousness but much of our
behavior much of what we're doing is
happening outside of awareness so are
over or you're already halfway there
before you realizing oh where am I going
what am i doing and so if we had to be
consciously aware of every single move
we made we would the brain doesn't have
the capacity to do that consciousness
has a limited to capacity capacity but
the unconscious processes seems to be
unlimited which is not to say we also
couldn't call that free will right in an
unconscious way you're unconsciously
making decisions freely all the time we
only have time for two more questions
I'm sorry for the rest of the line there
sir okay well I see someone really young
in the line there sir I'm not referring
to you we'll take the last two here and
just one more over there sir okay the
question is kind of following up on the
issue of awareness and heightened
awareness and the use of psychotropic
drugs and a hallucinogenics in treatment
of brain disorders oh okay yeah so and
what I have one other question how many
people on the panel are left-handed
[Laughter]
once again left-handed people have
certain advantages certain things well
you add the hilarious old joke you want
your kid to grow up to be a left-handed
relief pitcher because he or she is
gonna let so far make more money
actually people who are left-handed have
less lateralization so language tends to
be more lateral it's not completely in
the left brain but lateralization
learn more activate like more activation
in one hemisphere of the brain than the
other so like language tends to be
lateral eyes or there's more activation
in the left hemisphere but people who
are left-handed there tends to be more
activation in the right hemisphere above
and beyond those her right hands is so
there's less lateralization there's more
sort of distributed across the brain
activation I'm about 20 percent
left-handed but the point of the drugs
to treatment they're actually now
studies at where I'm at they're using
ketamine's as a treatment for depression
which used to be a club drug called
Special K and if you take too much of it
you can dissociate it's not good we're
doing that later
[Music]
I think also treatment for depression
that's it's sort of one set but there
also there is a field that's looking at
sort of understanding altered states of
consciousness and our perception of
altered states of consciousness and even
using drugs like ecstasy for therapy and
treatment for PTSD their therapeutic lis
with with sort of well trained and and
and very elaborate supervision it can be
a quick follow-up on that
alright Heather is there any mental
state beyond the one that is alert and
bright that can be chemically induced
that is a greater mental state of
awareness than the one you started with
so because it appears that every time
you do anything chemical to the brain it
disrupts your ability to know what
reality is the first of all even just in
our non drug-induced State our
perception is different than what's
necessarily out there in reality sure
there's all sorts of illusions you don't
see what's right in front of your oh
yeah so there's that so anytime you but
add a certain kind of chemical you
change the the neuro chemistry of the
brain it's not going to say that you're
gonna be more aware you're just gonna
have a different type of awareness
perception but when you have things like
synesthesia when you have senses
crossing from LSD those kinds of
experiences you know these are these are
kind of qualitative or quantitative
questions right yes you're having more
experiences that are much more
complicated and much more you know
trippy than what we're experiencing
[Laughter]
[Music]
pressure for the last question something
I've always been fascinated with you
guys talked about like telekinesis
mind-reading and all that where does the
job who fall into the spectrum we've all
experienced that we've all had that
moment or many moments that we know it's
coming but we don't know why have you
asked
[Laughter]
I got I waited for one of you I'm sorry
it's only because I had already heard us
night
have you heard George Carlin comment on
danger he says he ever walked into a
room and you were sure it has never
happened to you before so so deja vu a
week what do you guys say about that so
I'm not an expert in this area but I
think that there's a sense that you
something is triggered in the brain
where you get a sense of familiarity and
then you attribute that so what's
happening around you and there's also
studies that show when you lose that
sense of familiarity some people think
that a person they know very well is an
impostor so they think like their
husband or wife is an alien because they
lose the sense of familiarity but and
sometimes that that same neuro circuit
is activated in any situation and they
feel like they've been there before they
and that's I think that's sort of
speaking to the sort of redundancy that
occurs in the brain that the notion is
that there there are many ways to get to
one destination and sometimes pathways
get triggered that have this sort of
this sense of familiarity because you've
you've literally activated a pathway
that is redundant I mean everything's
got to fit in there sure there's miles
and miles and miles but there are
certain things that are going to trigger
redundant kind of pathways that also
again have that sense of I've done this
before and your brain thinks it has yeah
and also the other thing with that
memories are or malleable each time you
remember something you can reconstruct
it it's different than the memory of
your iPhone the picture that you look at
will stay the same you know 10,000 years
now that picture will be exactly the
same but every time you remember
something it slightly changes so we can
rewrite history in a way the last
question of the evening yes if someone
was born in space how would that affect
the way their brain develops
[Applause]
well a play you're nine that's my
bedtime is your bedtime when you see
your parents let them know they're
irresponsible
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's a brilliant question first of all
second I can take it only so far maybe
heather has and and and my um have some
other comments on that but there are a
lot of things in our lives that you know
we work we evolved to be on earth with
our force of gravity and the kind of
light that's here and so they're all
these things that shape what eventually
we call common sense and things fall
down when you let go of them fact the
act of saying let go means to drop it
whereas in space letting go doesn't drop
it it just sort of stays there so your
awareness of what is normal is really
different and we don't really know it's
it's kind of unethical at this point to
just do that experiment send up let's
see what happens to my kid after she's
born in zero-g you know so so we don't
really know but there from the
experiments done there are things about
your ears inside your ear you get a
sense of balance okay your ears tell
it's oh say at the fitness center I do
that little balance thing so you alright
so your bet your sense of balance comes
about because you're in a gravity field
if you got born in space and that's all
you know and then we put you here on
earth
heavy did you see the end of the movie
gravity in it in it Sandra Bullock who's
been a long time in space
she only accurate part of it she crawls
up on the beach and she realizes she
hasn't had to walk in a long time her
sense of balance had grown accustomed to
being in zero-g and had forgotten what
it was like to walk on earth
octi I got it I got it interject this do
it
you don't know that don't know what you
don't know that if a kid were born in
space that he or she came back to earth
couldn't figure it out
you don't know Ike he or she may have
actually a whole different deeper
understanding of inertia and physics and
friction that I admit we don't want to
run that test he's Uncle Bill is right
we don't know okay close this guess his
sons a bullet
yeah your best evidence is what happened
at the end of the movie gravity that's
the time thank you all for coming to
start
you